die Schrecken des Krieges treiben die
Menschen in der Ukraine in die
Verzweiflung und viele tausend schon aus
dem Land
Verwüstungen und verwundete fast 200
Zivilisten sollen nach Angaben der
Regierung bislang getötet worden sein
Präsident selensky ruft seine Landsleute
dazu auf ihre Heimat zu verteidigen und
nicht russischen Falschinformationen
aufzusitzen auch er der Präsident hart
in Kiew weiter aus
Tag 3 der russischen Invasion in der
Ukraine und wenig deutet darauf hin dass
dieses Blut vergießen schon bald ein
Ende haben könnte und damit herzlich
willkommen zu diesem ZDF Spezial
wer glaubt Krieg ist wenn zwei Armeen
Aufeinandertreffen wenn sich Soldaten
gegenseitig unter Beschuss nehmen der
hätte es schon vor dem Überfall
Russlands besser wissen können in diesem
Krieg aber wird der endgültig eines
Besseren belehrt dieser Krieg nämlich
tobt spätestens seit heute früh auch in
ukrainischen Großstädten was das für
Frauen für Kinder für alte Menschen
bedeutet welches Leid der russische
Vormarsch der Zivilbevölkerung zufügt
diese Bilder können und wollen wir ihnen
nicht ersparen Gerd Anhalt fast zusammen
was fassungslos macht
ein kalter strahlender morgen in Kiew
nach einer langen und Bangen Nacht für
die der Fall der Hauptstadt nicht
ausgeschlossen schien aber die
Verteidigungslinien scheinen gehalten zu
haben
und zwar klar dass die Nacht schwierig
werden würde denn die Russen wollten uns
größtmöglichen Schaden zufügen aber das
ist ihnen nicht gelungen
drang aus den Vororten es gab Angriffe
vor allem auf Militäranlagen und
Flughäfen sowie ein Kraftwerk
am Morgen präsentierten die Verteidiger
dann die Trümmer eines zerstörten
russischen Konvois der vor der
Hauptstadt gestoppt worden sei insgesamt
so dass Militär wurden bisher über 500
russische Fahrzeuge zerstört sowie 102
Panzer und 14 Flugzeuge Bürgermeister
Klitschko meldete sich mit einer
beruhigenden Botschaft Freunde und
Bürger von Kiew diese Nacht war hart
aber es sind keine russischen Truppen in
die Stadt vorgedrungen sie versuchen es
weiter vor allem von Osten her aber wir
haben sie zurückgeschlagen
35 Einwohner seien in der Nacht
verwundet worden darunter zwei Kinder
und weithin sichtbar zeugte ein von
einer Rakete getroffenes Wohnhaus in der
Nähe des Flughafens von den Gefechten um
die 2,8 Millionen statt ein Angriff den
es nach Aussagen der russischen Seite
gar nicht gegeben haben kann
lassen Sie mich noch einmal betonen dass
unsere Angriffe nur den Einrichtungen
der ukrainischen Armee gelten und das
schließt Schäden an Wohngebäuden aus
Zusicherungen auf die sich die
kiefer-bevölkerung oft aus eigener
Erfahrung nicht verlassen möchte
weiter versuchen tausende die Hauptstadt
zu verlassen die U-Bahn-Stationen sind
Anlaufstellen für alle die die
Ungewissheit nicht mehr ertragen
das schlimmste ist ja man weiß nicht wie
das alles hier ausgeht und wann
Mitfahrgelegenheiten und private
Taxifahrten werden hier für die
angeboten die sich das leisten können
aber die Fahrt hinaus ist auch nichts
für schwache Nerven wie das britische
Fernsehteam feststellt bewaffnete
Milizionäre halten sie an um sie zu
kontrollieren überall ist Militär
eine Familie auf der Flucht wir können
nicht mehr nach Hause sagt die Frau mit
dem Baby auf dem Arm als der Reporter
die Oma nach ihrer Meinung zu Putin
fragt Geschützfeuer
das da das ist Putin sagt sie und weiter
geht die Reise vielleicht nach Westen
vielleicht Richtung Polen wo sich wie
Satellitenbilder zeigen vor der Grenze
bereits ein über sechs Kilometer langer
Stau gebildet hatte der inzwischen noch
länger geworden sein dürfte weil auch in
der Nacht der Strom der Fahrzeuge nicht
abriss und auch viele einfach zu Fuß die
Grenze auf die sichere Seite überqueren
in Polen allein sollen nach
Behördenangaben inzwischen
hunderttausend Menschen eingetroffen
sein freiwillige Helfer versorgen die
Ankömmlinge mit warmen Mahlzeiten und
provisorischer Unterkunft für die erste
Nacht
werden beschossen wir wollten nicht
warten bis sie auch lief angreifen und
habe schnell gepackt und sind los mein
Sohn ist noch nicht einmal ein Jahr alt
und ich bin sehr in Sorge um seine
Zukunft ich
und wenn man zum Beispiel auf den
Bahnhof von Liv dem alten Lemberg im
Westen der Ukraine schaut dann wird
schnell klar dass diese Sorge von
abertausenden geteilt wird die sich noch
auf den Weg machen wollen
immer wieder werden über die sozialen
Medien Nachrichten verbreitet nach denen
auch der Staatschef das Land verlassen
habe dem trat wohl oder mir selensky am
Morgen mit einer Videobotschaft entgegen
mit dem Handy aufgenommen vor dem Haus
der Chimären einem bekannten Wahrzeichen
gleich gegenüber seinem Amtssitz in Kiew
im Netz gibt es viele Fake News sagte
aber ich bin hier wir geben nicht auf
wir werden unser Land verteidigen
und gleichzeitig rollt von Osten her der
Angriff da berichtet das russische
Fernsehen über Vorstöße der Separatisten
ein panzerkur ohne Hoheitsabzeichen
rollt westwärts wann und wo diese
Aufnahmen entstanden das wird nicht
erwähnt viel wichtiger sind ohnehin die
patriotischen die pro-russischen
Botschaften
wir verteidigen unsere Heimat unsere
Kinder unsere Häuser darauf haben wir
seit acht Jahren gewartet
mit Bildern aus den Landesteilen weiter
westlich und aus Kiew hält sich das
Moskauer Fernsehen bisher zurück
vielleicht weil es da nicht ganz so
läuft wie geplant
ja über das Kriegsgeschehen in der
Ukraine zu berichten objektiv zu
berichten das ist für ausländischer
Journalisten fast unmöglich geworden die
meisten Medien haben ihre Reporter aus
den umkämpfgebieten zu Meister auch aus
der Hauptstadt Kiew abgezogen und aus
der Landes gebracht aber für das ZDF
berichtet meine Kollegin Katrin
Eickendorf nun aus Venezia das liegt
knapp 300 Kilometer südwestlich von Kiew
Katrin das klingt zunächst weit weg von
den Kämpfen im ganzen Land aber ist es
das wirklich was kriegen die Menschen
bei Ihnen mit vom Krieg
das ist zwar geografisch von Kiew
Luftlinie 200 Kilometer entfernt aber
natürlich findet der Krieg auch hier in
dieser Region statt also wir haben hier
letzte Nacht auch
Luftalarm erlebt wir erleben hier auch
in der Nähe der Stadt wurde ein
russisches Kampfflugzeug abgeschossen
und natürlich bekommen wir hier auch die
Informationen aus Kiew was dort im
Prinzip jede Stunde sich ändert es ist
so dass in der Tat sich das
Kampfgeschehen jetzt um die ukrainische
Hauptstadt dreht denn Putins ziel ist es
ja die Regierung dort zu entmachten mit
jeder Stunde die dieser Krieg länger
dauert wachsen im Prinzip die Appelle
der Regierung also auf der einen Seite
des Bürgermeisters von Kiew Vitali
Klitschko aber auch des Präsidenten
selensky an die Bevölkerung
durchzuhalten sich zur Wehr zu setzen
die Ruhe zu bewahren und es sieht so aus
als ob für die russischen Truppen das
russische Militär
Eroberung Kiews nicht so einfach ist wie
sie ursprünglich geglaubt hatten und um
den Kampfhandlungen zu entgehen sollen
sich bereits über 100.000 Menschen ja
landesweite auf die Flucht gemacht haben
gen Westen von Venezia wo sie sind sind
es ungefähr 100 Kilometer bis zur
moldawischen Grenze packt wer kann jetzt
tatsächlich die Koffer
ich habe Ihre Frage akustisch nicht
verstanden bitte noch mal packt jetzt
tatsächlich packen viele Menschen die
sie beobachten dort auch in Venezia
jetzt die Koffer machen sich auf den Weg
gern Süden oder auch gen Westen
das müssen wir natürlich relativieren im
Vergleich zur Gesamtbevölkerung sind das
sicherlich nicht viele europa muss mit
wachsenden Flüchtlingsströmen ganz
sicher rechnen wir gehen im Moment von
100.000 mindestens aus und die Zahl der
Flüchtlinge wird natürlich noch wachsen
das hier ist einer der Durchgangsorte
und wir erleben hier viele Familien die
auf gepacktem Koffern sitzen aber auf
der anderen Seite erleben wir eben viel
viel mehr Menschen die entschlossen sind
hier im Land zu bleiben und im Prinzip
für die Ukraine zu kämpfen also es wir
hören immer wieder von Menschen dass sie
sagen das geht hier um die Zukunft
unseres Landes und wir können das nicht
einfach aufgeben Männer haben auch gar
nicht die Option das Land zu verlassen
zwischen 18 und 60-Jährige müssen hier
bleiben sind im Prinzip zu den Waffen
gerufen also mein Eindruck ist im Moment
eher dass die ukrainische Bevölkerung
hier dafür einsteht das Land zu
verteidigen
und diejenigen nämlich vor allem Frauen
und Kinder auch ältere Menschen die das
Land verlassen kommen jetzt größtenteils
in die Slowakei und nach Polen auch
dorthin werden wir im Laufe der Sendung
noch schalten Katrin danke für diese
Eindrücke schon aus dem dunklen Venezia
ja selbst wäre noch ein halbwegs
normales Leben führen kann weil die
Kämpfe in sicherer Entfernung toben wird
sich fragen wann dieser Krieg an seine
Haustür klopft für weite Teile der
Ukraine ist der Kriegszustand bereits
Realität geworden im Don Bass und dem
Küstengebiet des Schwarzen Meeres stehen
sich russische und ukrainische Soldaten
direkt gegenüber werden militärische
Ziele und offenbar auch zivile
Einrichtungen dem Erdboden gleichgemacht
in Kiew oder sogar ein Hochhaus
getroffen der Krieg hat auch die
Hauptstadt mit voller Wucht erreicht
Cornelia Donath
es ist 8:12 Uhr Ortszeit Kiew als die
Rakete in das Hochhaus einschlägt ein
Loch klafft zwischen dem 18 und 21 Stock
Retter tragen Verletzte aus dem Gebäude
in der lobanowskystraße 6a im Südwesten
der Hauptstadt ganz in der Nähe des
Flughafens siekorski
wir suchen weiter nach verletzten bis
jetzt haben wir sechs gefunden zwei
Stockwerke standen in Flammen 80
Menschen konnten wir evakuieren
in der Nacht durchdringen immer wieder
Schüsse und Explosionen die Dunkelheit
sogar rund 800 Meter vom
Regierungsviertel entfernt waren
Detonationen zu hören
am Morgen zeigen sich auch hier nah
einer Bahnstation die Trümmer der
vergangenen Nacht den Menschen steckt
der Schock in den Knochen ein großes
Glück für Sie die Gleise wurden nicht
zerstört
es ist schrecklicher Terrorismus das
denken wir alten ich werde 84 wir sind
alle besorgt um die Anbindung hier denn
die ist unser Leben so kommen wir auf
den Markt
nach Kämpfen im Norden der Stadt meldet
das ukrainische Energieministerium die
eigenen Truppen halten die Kontrolle
über das dortige Wasserkraftwerk
unklar hingegen soll die Lage auf dem
Flughafen hostomol sein 7 km von Kiew
entfernt zwar zeigen Fotos einen
abgeschossenen russischen Hubschrauber
aber das russische Militär hat nach
eigenen Angaben den Flughafen
eingenommen so könnte es Soldaten direkt
an den Stadtrand von Kiew fliegen
außerdem sollen dort Truppen eintreffen
die von Belarus aus über Tschernobyl auf
die Hauptstadt vorstoßen das Kraftwerk
liegt für die Russen strategisch wichtig
direkt an der Straße nach Kiel nur 120
km entfernt
in vasylkiff südlich von Kiew wollten
laut der Bürgermeisterin russische
Fallschirmjäger einen Militärstützpunkt
einnehmen nach heftigen Kämpfen und
schweren Verlusten habe der Angriff
jedoch abgewehrt werden können bestätigt
ist das nicht
Milito Paul im Südosten hingegen soll
das russische Militär erobert haben und
damit eine erste größere ukrainische
Stadt auch hier fehlt die Bestätigung
die Angriffe gehen auch im Osten des
Landes weiter in Rakel der zweitgrößten
Stadt sowie in Lohans und dorniert
bei den Kämpfen der letzten Nacht ist
hier die Wasserversorgung zerstört
worden jetzt stehen die Menschen an um
ihre Flaschen zu füllen Tag 3 im Krieg
der für sich hier in den besetzten
Gebieten schon so viel länger dauert die
kleinen Betten und der Spielplatz lassen
vermuten auch ein Kinderheim wurde
getroffen
ja die militärische Lage das
Kriegsgeschehen selbst von außen
beurteilen zu können ist für den Laien
praktisch unmöglich und selbst für den
Experten eine Herausforderung denn man
ist eben auf ungesicherte Informationen
angewiesen versuchen wir es trotzdem mit
Bundeswehr general ade Egon Rams zur
guten Abend guten Abend
was ich gestern bereits angedeutet hatte
bestätigt nun heute auch das Pentagon
das nämlich die russischen Streitkräfte
auf sehr hartnäckigen widerstandsstoßen
gerade im Norden der Ukraine nicht so
rasch vorrücken können wie sie es
vermutlich geplant hatten woran liegt
das aus ihrer Sicht
also ich gehe davon aus dass die Russen
sich einen bestimmten Plan gemacht haben
wo sie ich sage mal mit bestimmten
tagesschritten Ziele erreichen wollten
und das ist offensichtlich nach der
Neuformierung der ukrainischen Abwehr
vorgestern nicht mehr so einfach möglich
wie man sich das vorgestellt hat etwa
die Hälfte der rund um die Ukraine
stationierten Truppen sollen im Einsatz
sein auf russischer Seite könnten die
russischen Streitkräfte nicht eigentlich
jeden Tag massiv verstärken wenn sie
merken dass sie zum Beispiel im Norden
Probleme haben
also ist ein strategischer Ansatz
gewesen der Russen oder sogar früher
schon der Sowjetunion dass man
staffelweise einen solchen Angriff führt
das heißt ich gehe zur Zeit noch davon
aus dass die erste Staffel der
russischen Kräfte im Einsatz ist und es
bleibt abzuwarten aufgrund welche
Ereignisse auf der einen Seite und mit
welchem zeitlichen Ablauf diese zweite
Staffel dann möglicherweise eingeführt
wird aus russischer Sicht günstiger
verhält sich die Lage im Südosten der
Ukraine also an der Schwarzmeerküste die
Stadt melittopol das ist ein wichtiges
Industriezentrum ist gefallen die
Hafenstadt mariopol wohl heftig umkämpft
worum geht es den Russen eigentlich in
der Schwarzmeerregion welche Bedeutung
hat für Sie die Südflanke
also ich vermute das ist eine Absicht
der Russen sein wird möglichst schnell
einen Weg ein Landweg zur Krim zu
etablieren und dem dienen diese Angriffe
wobei eben wenn mein Kenntnisstand
richtig ist aber mit aller Vorsicht
dabei offensichtlich auch amphibische
Kräfte eingesetzt worden sind und es ist
eine weitere Frage auch für die Russen
wie lange kann man diesen amphibischen
Angriff nehmen
zur Abschreckung Russlands stockt er die
NATO jetzt ihre Präsenz an der ostwanke
auf die Eingreiftruppe wurde in höchster
Alarmbereitschaft versetzt ist das
eigentlich mehr als Symbolik oder hat
das eben tatsächlich auch faktisch eine
abschreckende Wirkung um zu verhindern
dass die Russen auch nur darüber
nachdenken nato-grenzen zu überschreiten
das ist der eine Teil den sie gerade
gesagt haben die NATO muss zeigen dass
sie in der Lage ist Kräfte in die an die
Ostgrenze der NATO zu verlegen die NATO
ist ein Verteidigungsbündnis diese
Kräfte werden dort nur zur Verteidigung
Anführungszeichen nur zur Verteidigung
hingebracht die NF über die wir jetzt
reden die nächste response hat eine
Stärke ich sage das mal von rund 50.000
Soldaten das heißt das ist dann schon
ein Fund was die Nato hat nach meinem
Kenntnisstand ist bisher über den Ort
oder den örtlichen Bereich wo diese
Kräfte hin verlegt worden sind noch
nicht entschieden auch die Bundeswehr
soll sich ja jetzt an der Verstärkung
der Ostflanke beteiligen unter anderem
mit einer Infanterie Kompanie die
Korvette Erfurt ist heute Vormittag
schon von Wilhelmshaven aus aufgebrochen
ist das ein wirklich substanzieller
ausreichender Beitrag Deutschlands zur
Verstärkung dieser nato-ostflanke
also um die gesamte Verstärkung
beurteilen zu können müsste man wissen
was an weiteren Kräften noch verlegt
wird oder von anderen Ländern verlegt
wird es ist ein Beitrag Deutschlands der
ist bisher sage ich mal mit aller
Vorsicht noch nicht allzu groß aber wir
müssen auch daran denken dass wir wenn
die NRF losgeht beispielsweise mit der
mit der jägerbrigade 7 oder Brigade 37
die sich zurzeit auf einen Einsatz im
nächsten Jahr vorbereitet mit beteiligt
sein werden von daher wird der Beitrag
Deutschlands dann im Laufe der Zeitung
auf der Zeitachse anwachsen und vor ein
paar Minuten wird gemeldet dass
Deutschland nun auch die Lieferung von
400 ehemals deutschen Panzerfäusten
durch einen Drittstaat an die Ukraine
genehmigen will also auch da scheint
sich ja ein Umdenken anzudeuten was
zumindest indirekte Waffenlieferungen an
die Ukraine betrifft
jawohl das ist eine gute Feststellung
wenn sie denn so zutrifft auch die
müsste auch von deutscher Seite noch mal
offiziell bestätigt werden das würde
dann möglicherweise auch in der Analogie
zur Freigabe dieser berühmten Haubitzen
der ehemaligen Volksarmee der DDR dieses
zurzeit in Estland befinden freigeben
können denn das ist im Prinzip dann der
gleiche Sachverhalt dann Olaf Scholz
hatte ja bisher eine Lieferung zumindest
tödlicher Waffen an die Ukraine
ausgeschlossen direkt geliefert wird
sicherlich auch weiterhin nicht aber das
wäre doch dann eine zumindest ja leichte
Veränderung der bisherigen Berliner
Haltung general Rams ich danke Ihnen für
das Gespräch danke gerne vielen Dank
das erste Opfer des Krieges ist die
Wahrheit ein dictum der spätestens seit
dem Ersten Weltkrieg gilt seit die
mächtigen die ihre Truppen an die Front
geschickt haben eine zweite Front
bedienen nämlich die der
Falschinformation sei es um den Gegner
zu täuschen sei es um die eigene
Bevölkerung moralisch aufzurichten wer
einen Angriffskrieg beginnt will ihn
rechtfertigen mindestens vor den eigenen
Untertanen die sollen glauben sie würden
für die Sicherheit des eigenen Landes
oder für die Befreiung eines brudervolks
kämpfen für Moskau spielt dieses
narrativ eine erkennbar wichtige Rolle
im Ukrain der Krieg dieser Überfall so
die Erzählung ist gar kein Überfall
sondern Notwehr
es war eine freie geheime allgemeine
Wahl am 21 April 2019 bei der wolimir
selensky mit 73% der Stimmen zum
Präsidenten der Ukraine gewählt wurde
russlands Präsident Putin dagegen
spricht von einer volksfeindlichen
runter die mit Hilfe eines fingierten
Wahlverfahrens die Ukraine als Geisel
genommen habe mit solchen
Falschinformationen deutet der Kreml
Chef die Wahrheit um im Osten der
Ukraine seien es nicht pro russische
Separatisten die seit Jahren Krieg
führen sondern die Ukraine verübe dort
einen Genozid an Millionen von Menschen
solche Behauptungen stützt die russische
Seite auch auf Bilder die gefälscht und
offensichtlich inszeniert sind
hier sollen nadon jetzt ukrainische
Saboteure ein ziviles Auto angegriffen
haben bei dem Angriff seien mehrere
Zivilisten zu Tode gekommen berichtet
ein Reporter im Fahrzeug sind
anscheinend die fast vollständig
verbrannten Überreste mehrerer Menschen
zu sehen ein Leichnam allerdings weist
am Schädel die glatten Schnitte einer
Knochensäge auf das typische Bild nach
einer Autopsie am verbrannten Fahrzeug
fehlen die Nummernschilder alles deutet
auf eine Inszenierung hin wurden hier
bereits verstorbene Menschen als Opfer
eines ukrainischen Anschlags präsentiert
eindeutig manipuliert ist dieses Video
angeblich stirbt hier ein Saboteur im
Auftrag der Ukraine der sich angeblich
selbst mit einer Helmkamera bei seinem
sabotage-angriff filmt im Hintergrund
die Geräusche eines schweren Gefechts
vermutlich hat dieses Gefecht nie
stattgefunden denn Experten haben in den
Metadaten des Videos nachgewiesen dass
die Tonspur gefälscht ist der Ton ist
kopiert worden von diesem Youtube-Video
das eine finnische Armee Übung zeigt die
Tonspuren beider Videos sind absolut
identisch
auch dieser angebliche Angriff der
Ukraine auf Stellungen der Separatisten
ist nicht das was die russische Seite
behauptet wieder soll ein Ukrainer mit
der eigenen Helmkamera gefilmt haben
bevor er angeblich getötet wurde das
kann nicht stimmen Journalisten konnten
den Ort der Videoaufnahmen zweifelsfrei
bestimmen weit entfernt von den
behaupteten Kampfhandlungen
in den russischen Medien aber auch in
sozialen Netzwerken weltweit verbreiten
solche Bilder die russische Version des
Konflikts
[Applaus]
und so ist Russlands Krieg in Putins
Sprache kein Krieg keine Invasion
sondern eine
spezialoperation um Russland unser Volk
zu verteidigen
dazu passt das hier russische
Medienaufsicht heute Einheimischen
Medien verboten hat den Angriff auf die
Ukraine als Angriff als Invasion oder
eben namentlich Kriegserklärung zu
bezeichnen Christiansen in Moskau was
droht denn Journalisten die den Krieg
trotzdem beim Namen nennen
er ist droht auf jeden Fall Ärger sie
haben es gerade angesprochen die
Medienaufsichtsbehörde hat zehn
verschiedenen russischen Medien also
online Medien Zeitung einen Antrag
zugestellt und sie aufgefordert gewisse
Inhalte zu entfernen die
Aufsichtsbehörde sagt das seien falsche
Informationen über den Krieg und die
Unternehmen sollten dem Nachkommen das
wird auch konkret gedroht mit
Strafzahlung 5 Millionen Rubel sein
fällig wenn man das nicht tut das sind
mehr als 5000 Euro die diese
Medienunternehmen dann zahlen müssten
und was dann weiter folgt kann man jetzt
noch nicht absehen da sind der
Kreativität im Prinzip ja keine Grenzen
gesetzt ist könnte dann eben auch noch
weitere Strafmaßnahmen geben oder auch
eine Schließung drohen und wir haben das
in der Vergangenheit ja auch schon
erlebt im Zusammenhang mit der Proteste
gegen alexener valny und der
Berichterstattung verschiedener Medien
das ist da große Probleme gab dass sie
danach tituliert wurden als ausländische
Agent was es den Medien sehr schwer
macht weiter zu arbeiten weil das mit
Restriktionen verbunden ist und da kann
also noch einiges drohen noch aber gibt
es ein paar unabhängige Medien in
Russland den Radiosender Moskau bei Echo
oder die Zeit genug war ja Gazzetta
sicher auch etliche Websites und Blogs
wie haben die bisher über diesen Krieg
berichtet
ja sie sagen es einige gibt es noch aber
nicht mehr viele zum Beispiel die novaya
gazeta also die Zeitung des
Friedensnobelpreisträgers dimit murator
der ist dort Chefredakteur die aktuelle
Ausgabe sieht so aus vielleicht kann ich
die mal kurz zeigen das ist das
Titelblatt der Ausgabe von gestern und
darauf steht Russland bombardiert die
Ukraine und die Zeitung spricht auch von
einer Schande das ist ein mutiger Titel
und wir können davon ausgehen dass das
für Probleme sorgen wird und noch für
einen Echo sorgen wird die anderen
freien Medien die es noch gibt die
berichten dann vor allem auf ihren
Webseiten sehr differenziert mit
Kommentaren mit Videos und versuchen
sozusagen das ganze Ausmaß dieses
Angriff darzustellen wie wir das in
unserer Medienlandschaft von von
differenzierten objektiven Medien
gewohnt sind
die Ausgabe der novaja Gazetta die Sie
gerade hoch gehalten haben war das jene
Ausgabe die nicht nur in russischer
sondern auch in ukrainischer Sprache
zumindest was das Titelblatt angeht
ja das ist richtig kannst ja vielleicht
gerade noch mal zeigen also hier ist
Russisch hier ist ukrainisch und wenn
man die Zeitung aufschlägt es ist alles
in schwarz gehalten was natürlich die
das Mitgefühl und die Trauer auch
symbolisieren soll und ganz bewusst ist
das zweisprachig gehalten weil es heißt
so schreiben Sie auch im Editorial
das Ukrainisch nicht die Sprache des
Feindes ist
eine Aktion die der Redaktion oder die
die Redaktion sicherlich viel Mut kostet
und ja welche Konsequenzen
staatlicherseits so etwas hat das bleibt
auch zu warten Christian danke nach
Moskau
ja die Wahrheit verdrehen oder dreist
lügen um den Weltenlauf zum eigenen
Vorteil zu drehen das ist die Aufgabe
russischer
Desinformationskampagnen die ja schon
vor dem Ukraine Krieg deutlich
zugenommen haben dass jedenfalls
beobachtet die EU die zur Abwehr eine
entsprechende Task Force gegründet hat
und ihr Leiter ist uns nun aus Paris
zugeschaltet zur guten Tag Herr Güldner
guten Abend wie sehr hat sich denn ja
das russische Karussell kursierender
Falschinformationen beschleunigt seit
Beginn dieses Krieges
ja diese Aktivitäten der Manipulation
auf ganz vielen Ebenen hat sich enorm
beschleunigt aber nicht erst seit
Ausbruch der Kampfhandlungen sondern
schon in den Tagen in den Wochen
vielleicht sogar in den Monaten davor wo
wir ganz eng auf aber aufeinander
abgestimmte Erzählungen mitbekommen
haben auch dokumentiert haben die immer
wieder darum ging Russland als Opfer
darzustellen den Westen die Ukraine als
Aggressor und jetzt hat sich das
natürlich durch die Kampfhandlungen auch
noch mal zusätzlich beschleunigt im all
dem was der was die Kriegshandlungen
anbelangt also es praktisch krass
klassische Kriegspropaganda gehen da
diese Kampagne die sie beobachten vor
allem von staatlichen russischen Quellen
aus oder auch von solchen die vom Kreml
möglicherweise beauftragt worden sind
ja das sind beides also wir sprechen von
einem ganzen Ökosystem an
desinformationsquellen da sind zum Teil
die staatlichen Akteure die staatlichen
Medien die man ja auch relativ einfach
identifizieren kann aber da hängen dann
eine ganze Reihe von
Informationsportalen und auch auf den
sozialen Medien verschiedene Akteure
daran einige von denen sind sogar durch
die russischen Geheimdienste gesteuert
also das ist ein Netzwerk das da bedient
wird sie selbst leiten ja nun eine
Taskforce die Brüssel schon 2015
eingesetzt hat um russischer
Desinformation etwas entgegenzusetzen
was können Sie entgegensetzen
ich glaube das wichtigste ist
tatsächlich Transparenz das Aufdecken
dieser Aktivitäten immer wieder zeigen
wer macht da was welche Methoden werden
verwendet wie wird die Manipulation
eigentlich durchgeführt und das machen
wir nicht nur mit einer Website sondern
auch mit vielen Partnern international
in der Zivilgesellschaft ich glaube dass
das eins der wichtigsten Elemente dass
wir haben und natürlich auch immer
wieder unsere eigene Stimme hören lassen
um zu zeigen wo die Lügen bzw auch wo
dieser Manipulation stattfindet was wäre
das konkrete Ziel was den Kriegsverlauf
angeht wie meinen sie können Sie mit
Ihrer Arbeit dazu beitragen des
Information in diesem Krieg zu bekämpfen
ja ganz abstellen werden wir das
wahrscheinlich nicht können aber was
eine Sache was sehr sehr wichtig ist ist
auf die Wortwahl zu achten also da
werden sehr viele
schönungen benutzt auf russischen Seiten
von der Angriffskrieg ist keine
Angriffskrieg sondern ist dann einfach
nur eine Aktion oder ähnliches also
selbst in der sehr in dieser Wortwahl
kann man schon einiges aufdecken und
natürlich wie dieses Netzwerk
funktioniert und sich ausbreitet und
benutzt wird Herr grüner danke für diese
Einblicke und Eindrücke nach Paris
vielen Dank
danke
und das Gespräch haben wir vor der
Sendung aufgezeichnet auch unser
nächstes Thema hat das Zeug zur
Zielscheibe von wahrheitsverdrehern und
Fake News Produzenten zu werden und das
ist denn diesem Fall umso erbärmlicher
da ist und das Schicksal derer geht die
in diesem Krieg alles zu verlieren haben
da vorsichtige Schätzungen sind bereits
100.000 Menschen in der Ukraine selbst
auf der Flucht zehntausende sollen die
Grenzen in die Nachbarländer bereits
überschritten haben eine neue
Flüchtlingswelle deren Vorboten schon
jetzt sichtbar sind
die Menschen kommen mit dem was sie
tragen können Frauen und Kinder die ihre
Männer und Väter zurücklassen mussten
die dürfen nicht über die Grenze sollen
kämpfen für ihr Land
seit Kriegsbeginn sind in Polen rund
100.000 Flüchtlinge aus dem Nachbarland
angekommen viele haben hier Freunde und
Verwandte schon lange leben in Polen
geschätzte anderthalb Millionen Ukraine
Flucht aus dem Krieg
es ist so schrecklich schrecklich mein
Herz bricht alle weinen
Explosionen Sirenen einfach nur
schrecklich
Stress noch
vor der Grenze stundenlanges Warten
zDF-Reporter Lothar Becker war auf der
anderen Seite in der Ukraine unterwegs
und berichtet von der Flucht
über 25 km zieht sich der Stau bis wir
den Grenzposten medica auf ukrainischer
Seite erreichen davor tausende
flüchtende meist Frauen und Kinder zu
Fuß stoisch ohne Panik warten Sie über
Stunden oder die ganze Nacht weil die
ukrainischen Grenzer nur stoßweise
kleine Gruppen durchlassen überall war
einen Kinder die Temperaturen längst
unter dem Gefrierpunkt Verpflegung
sanitäre Einrichtungen medizinische
Versorgung gibt es nicht nur die Kälte
eine humanitäre Katastrophe
auch im slowakischen Vision kommen
Kriegsflüchtlinge an Frauen und Kinder
ältere Männer hinter dem Schlagbaum
Europa Sicherheit Frieden
wollen mir Ivanov hat es geschafft
erzählt von der ersten kriegsnacht in
tscharke
das Haus fing an zu beben richtig zu
wackeln ich habe es erst nicht
verstanden ich dachte in der Nähe ist
ein Jugendclub da wird gefeiert und da
würde jemand Feuerwerk machen
es sind vor allem Freiwillige die hier
helfen patrick hat einen kleinen Tisch
aufgebaut versucht Flüchtlinge und
freiwillige zusammenzubringen
viele hier kommen um zu helfen sie
bieten Unterkünfte 30 60 oder sogar 200
Betten ich kam gestern nach der Arbeit
hierher um zu helfen und jetzt
organisiere ich das alles die Unterkunft
und den Transport
Anastasia war zehn Stunden unterwegs 450
km liegen hinter ihr
[Musik]
meine Mutter und mein Vater sind in der
Armee sie sind zu Hause geblieben
und Sie können nicht weg und sie haben
Freunde gefragt mich hierher zu bringen
mein Hund meine Eltern
und so stellen Sie sich hier ein auf
viele tausend Menschen die in den
nächsten Tagen den Weg in die Freiheit
suchen
ja zur ersten Anlaufstelle für Migranten
werden ja nun die Länder die eine
gemeinsame Grenze mit der Ukraine haben
Britta Hilpert ist in den äußersten
Osten der Slowakei gereist direkt an die
Grenze zur Ukraine von dort sind es rund
250 km nach Lemberg ja Britta gestern
kam ja eher noch vereinzelt Menschen aus
der Ukraine Frauen Kinder ältere denn
die Männer die Ukraine dürfen ja wenn
sie unter 60 Jahre alt sind nicht
ausreisen wie ist die Lage heute an der
Grenze
heute morgen hatte ich den Eindruck dass
mehr und das die Grenzübergänge
schneller geschehen jetzt im Augenblick
kommt es wieder nur stoßweise das was
Lothar Becker beobachtet hat auf der
ukrainischen Seite das erleben wir eben
auch hier es kommen immer mal wieder so
Grübchen an ungewöhnliches Grüppchen
hier aber es kommen in der Regel
Grübchen mit Frauen und Kindern und dann
kommt wieder lange nichts es scheint an
der Grenze sehr viel Bürokratie zu geben
die Pässe werden streng kontrolliert es
heißt vor allen Dingen von ukrainischer
Seite sehr groß ist die
Hilfsbereitschaft hier hier stehen sehr
sehr viele Menschen die helfen wollen
die gekommen sind aus Tschechien aus der
Slowakei auch viele deutsche habe ich
hier schon getroffen die anbieten
Transporte zu unternehmen Richtung
Westen die auch anbieten Leute
unterzubringen
wenn Sie mit dem Menschen sprechen wie
schätzen denn die Flüchtlinge selbst
ihre eigene Zukunft einen gehen die
davon aus jetzt nur vorübergehend ihr
Land zu verlassen oder doch für sehr
lange Zeit
also das muss ich sagen das ist
herzzerreißen weil ich habe keinen
getroffen der sagt ich stelle mich
darauf ein Monate hier zu bleiben
sondern alle hoffen natürlich dass Sie
so schnell wie möglich wieder nach Hause
können dass der Krieg bald vorbei ist
dass die Ukrainer gewinnen das habe ich
auch natürlich hier gehört aber sie
haben alle sehr große Koffer dabei und
sie tragen so viel sie nur können hier
rüber und ich denke sie hoffen auf das
Beste im Herzen aber der Verstand sagt
ihnen besser auf der Schlimmste
vorbereitet sein und in ihrem Koffer
auch die große Sorge wann sie denn ihre
Angehörigen vor allem ihre Männer Väter
Onkel Großväter in der Ukraine wieder
sehen können Britta danke für diese ja
eindrücklichen Beobachtungen von der
slowakisch ukrainischen Grenze
wenn das Kriegsgeschehen noch Tage oder
wochenlang anhält so schätzen zumindest
die Vereinten Nationen dann könnten sich
bis zu 4 Millionen Ukraine in Bewegung
setzen und auch Deutschland müsste sich
dann auf eine Lage einstellen die den
Sommer des Jahres 2015 wohl in den
Schatten stellen könnte gestern Abend
haben der Bundeskanzler und die
Ministerpräsidenten auch über die
mögliche Aufnahme von Flüchtlingen
gesprochen und wie man hört ist die
Aufnahmebereitschaft gerade auch in den
Bundesländern äußerst groß helfen kann
aber auch bedeuten diejenigen zu
unterstützen die noch in der Ukraine
ausharren wie eine kleine
Hilfsorganisation im Allgäu
vor sieben Jahren hat Wolfgang ponto aus
Wangen im Allgäu die Hilfsorganisation
Hop gegründet sie unterstützen der
Ukraine die Eltern von Schwerkranken und
pflegebedürftigen Kindern liefert
medizinisches Material für deren
Versorgung noch vor einer Woche war
ponto in Kiew der Krieg aber ändert nun
alles
also die Kinder mit mit SMA die in den
Bergen wohnen von uns versorgt wurden
ja müssen wir schauen denn es wenn sie
nichts bekommen ist es die Kinder waren
sterben
seine Lebensgefährtin und Lena
sikirinska arbeitet als Kinderärztin
lebt mit ihren beiden Kindern in Lemberg
immer wieder versucht ponto sie zu
erreichen will wissen ob sie ihn
Sicherheit sind doch in Lemberg ist
gerade Luftalarm sie müssen in dem
Bunker hallo
okay wo bist du momentan geht ihr gerade
runter oder
okay okay also können wir momentan kein
Gespräch machen gut weiß ich Bescheid
alles klar
bis später bis später alles Gute mein
Schatz tschüss
meine Familie
[Musik]
muss ich verstecken ich hoffe natürlich
dass alles alles gut geht
aber
ja sie wird sich dann nachher melden
wenn sie wieder hoch kann
in der Zwischenzeit bereitet Wolfgang
ponto im Lager schon die nächsten
Hilfslieferungen vor da ruft eine
befreundete Dolmetscherin aus der
Ukraine an bittet ponto eines ihrer zwei
Kinder an der Grenze abzuholen sie
selbst muss bleiben
ich kann einfach nicht so das Land die
Eltern verlassen und einfach fliehen
also
nur für mich fahren
wir
haben müssen da bleiben
okay
kurz darauf meldet sich seine
Lebensgefährtin aus Lemberg
war Angriff
das war nicht Angriff Angriff das war
nur Sirene Alarm okay
Entwarnung fürs erste die Angst aber
bleibt holina und Wolfgang vereinbaren
dass er sie so bald wie möglich an der
polnischen Grenze abholt sobald seine
Familie eine Fahrgelegenheit findet
heute am frühen Morgen ist ponto
aufgebrochen nach Polen es ist eine
Fahrt ins Ungewisse aber voller Hoffnung
auf ein baldiges Wiedersehen mit Olena
und ihren Kindern
und wenn Sie liebe Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer den Menschen in der Ukraine
helfen wollen dann spenden Sie bitte an
das Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe
Stichwort ZDF Nothilfe Ukraine die
IBAN-Nummer lautet
de65 100
600-100-400 600 alle Informationen auch
im Internet unter Spenden zdf.de oder im
ZDF Text auf Seite 890 dort können Sie
noch einmal alles in Ruhe nachlesen
wir haben es vorhin im Gespräch mit
General Rahms schon erwähnt die
Bundesregierung hat den Niederlanden die
Lieferung von 400 Panzerabwehrwaffen aus
deutscher Produktion an die Ukraine
genehmigt das haben zumindest zur
einzelnen Medien erfahren bisher hatte
die Bundesregierung ja alle Exporte
tödlicher Waffen an die Ukraine
prinzipiell abgelehnt eben weil es sich
dort um ein Krisengebiet handelt fragen
wir Theo Koll in Berlin können Sie das
bestätigen und wenn ja wäre das doch
schon eine rechte prononcierte
Veränderung in der deutschen
Rüstungspolitik oder ja zweimal ja also
ich kann es bestätigen ich habe mit dem
Regierungssprecher telefoniert und der
bestätigt das und nicht nur diese 400
Panzerabwehrwaffen diese Panzerfäuste
die in den Niederlanden Lagern sollen
auch die ominösen Haubitzen die in
Estland sind und die freigegeben werden
müssen von der Bundesregierung die aus
DDR Beständen sind und zusätzlich wird
man liefern 14 gepanzerte Fahrzeuge die
sind vor allem für Personenschutz
beziehungsweise für Evakuierungen
gedacht also wir haben es ja in den
vergangenen Tagen schon gespürt es ist
Bewegung in den Positionen der
Bundesregierung und bei den Waffen
Lieferungen sehen wir jetzt die ersten
Maßnahmen kann man davon ausgehen dass
diese Genehmigung jetzt tatsächlich auch
innerhalb der Ampelkoalition eng
abgestimmt ist man denke daran dass der
SPD-Fraktionschef Mütze nicht gerade
gestern glaube ich noch
Waffenlieferungen in Krisengebiete
abgelehnt hat und auch der Meinung war
dass Deutschland seinen weretat aufgrund
dieses Ukraine kriegs nicht unbedingt
wesentlich würde aufstocken müssen davon
kann man ausgehen dass das abgestimmt
ist und letztendlich entscheidet
natürlich dann der Bundeskanzler und
nicht der Fraktionsvorsitzende der SPD
es ist auf jeden Fall auch mit den
Grünen und der soweit ich weiß mit der
FDP abgestimmt also das ist die Haltung
der Bundesregierung im übrigen höre ich
dass es heute Abend auch noch eine
Telefon- oder Videokonferenz geben wird
mit sowohl dem amerikanischen
Präsidenten Frankreich Italien und
Berlin hier und es geht darum wie man
mit Swift umgeht und offensichtlich ist
die Linie dass man eine Art abgespeckte
sanktionsmaßnahme in Richtung Swift
verabschieden möchte indem man ganz
gezielt einige große Banken aus Swift
rausnimmt also einige russische Banken
ob die identisch sind mit den Banken um
die es bei den bisherigen
Sanktionsmaßnahmen gegen ist nicht ganz
klar das Problem für die Bundesregierung
ist und deswegen ist man auch jetzt so
isoliert bei der ganzen Debatte um Swift
und steht da im Grunde ganz alleine
dass man fürchtet dass die
energiekäufe die die Bundesregierung in
Russland vornimmt und vornehmen muss
dass man die nicht mehr bezahlen kann
wenn Swift abgeschaltet wird für
Russland und das dann in der Folge eben
auch nicht mehr geliefert wird also das
ist im Grunde die Abhängigkeit in der
die Bundesregierung da ist was
allerdings ohnehin obsolet würde wenn
Wladimir Putin den Gashahn nach
Deutschland zudreht drehte und dann
ohnehin nichts mehr zu bezahlen wäre
aber was hilft angeht scheint
Deutschland jedenfalls auch innerhalb
der Europäischen Union und da gab es ja
viel Kritik nicht länger auch der Bremse
stehen zu wollen ja in der Tat also
davon kann man ausgehen dass das heute
abend nach dieser Video- oder
Telefonkonferenz dann der beschlussstand
ist das sind spannende Entwicklungen
auch in der deutschen Innenpolitik Theo
call vor dem Hintergrund dass nun die
Bundesregierung also offenbar die
Lieferung von 400 ehemals deutschen
Panzerfäusten an die Ukraine erlaubt und
zwar durch die Niederlande Theo danke
für diese schnellen Auskünfte in die
Hauptstadt
und da bleiben wir fast ein bisschen
beim Thema Russland Lieferungen Energie
und Exporte wichtigster weizenlieferant
der Welt ist Russland auch führender
Hersteller von Wodka und eben natürlich
und davon war gerade schon die Rede
einer sprudelnde Ölquelle umgekehrt
zahlungskräftige Abnehmer von deutschen
maschinenbauprodukten von Technik und
Hochtechnologie kann Zweifel für Europa
und gerade für uns in Deutschland ist
bzw wahr Russland ein wichtiger
Handelspartner der ukrainekrieg ist eine
Hiobsbotschaft für die deutsche
Wirtschaft kaum scheint Corona halbwegs
überstanden schon rollt die nächste
Schockwelle und droht die deutsche
Konjunktur auszubremsen
es wird geschweißt und geschraubt bei
Zeppelin in Böblingen früher mal
luftschiffbauer heute verkaufen sie
amerikanische Baumaschinen der Marke
Caterpillar weltweit die Ukraine ein
wichtiger Markt mit einem Standort und
600 ortsansässigen Mitarbeitern seit
drei Tagen arbeitet die Firmenleitung
allerdings vor allem für deren
Sicherheit
kann Ihnen sagen wir haben Busse in die
kriegsregionen geschickt um unsere
Mitarbeiter dort rauszuholen einige
haben das in Anspruch genommen viele
sind auch einfach geblieben weil sie
gesagt haben wir müssen uns mit der
zukünftigen
Situationen auseinandersetzen und wir
wollen unsere Heimat nicht verlassen
erstmal geht es um die Menschen dann
aber auch ums Geschäft da stehen für
Zeppelin 800 Millionen euro-jahresumsatz
auf dem Spiel 20% des Gesamtgeschäfts
und das wird wohl nicht mehr wie es bis
vor drei Tagen einmal war
und wir werden in den nächsten Jahren
sicherlich die Märkte Ukraine und
Russland an das betrachten müssen und in
unseren Ausrichtungen dort auch anders
verfolgen müssen das heißt also das
heutige Geschäft wie wir es kennen in
Osteuropa in der Ukraine und in Russland
wird zukünftig für uns in der Form nicht
mehr stattfinden damit wird Zeppelin
nicht alleine stehen knapp 2000 deutsche
Unternehmen sind derzeit in der Ukraine
aktiv über 3.600 in Russland große
Player dort sind beispielsweise der
Metro Handelskonzern er betreibt 93
Märkte mit etwa 10.000 Mitarbeitern oder
der Chemieriese bASF hat 12 Werke mit
700 Mitarbeitern mercedes hat ein Werk
in der Nähe von Moskau mit 1000
Beschäftigten
der Hamburger Hafen Tor zur Welt
Sinnbild und Hotspot der Exportnation
einer der wichtigsten europäischen
Anlaufpunkte von hier ist St Petersburg
noch
2020 exportierte Deutschland Güter im
Wert von 26 Milliarden Euro nach
Russland 2% des gesamtexports wichtige
Güter waren Maschinen Autos
Elektrotechnik und Chemie
umgekehrt lieferte Russland vor allem
Rohstoffe natürlich Öl und Gas aber auch
Erze und Getreide
Energie und Mehl für die backstraßen bei
süßwarengigant Lambertz in Aachen wird
beides dringend benötigt Lebkuchen und
Printen machen Sie hier die Liebe zu
beiden Teilen Russen und Ukrainer nicht
nur an Weihnachten ein schöner
Wachstumsmarkt dachte Hermann bülbäcker
Chef der Lambertz Gruppe er investierte
vor vielen Jahren jetzt scheint alles in
Gefahr der Absatz die guten Beziehungen
die man viele Jahre pflegte und er ist
sich sicher Versorgungsschwierigkeiten
werden kommen für Lambertz und viele
andere Unternehmen
steigende Gas Öl Strompreise Aluminium
wird uns alle treffen wird auch dieses
Unternehmen wieder in seiner
Kostenstruktur treffen und wir sind
vielleicht auch besonders noch betroffen
insofern als Russland Weizen
Lieferant der Welt Nummer eins ist
Ukraine ist weizenanbauland in der Welt
Nummer 2 und sind natürlich auch sofort
gleich die Weizenpreise dramatisch
hochgegangen
Energiepreise werden weiter steigen
produzieren wir teurer Produkte damit
auch putinskrieg wird so auch
Deutschlands wirtschaftliches Leben
nachhaltig beeinflussen
natürlich macht man sich auch in den
Führungsetagen der deutschen Wirtschaft
Gedanken darüber was denn passiert wenn
Russlands Energielieferungen ganz zum
Erliegen kommen das nordstream 2 in
naher Zukunft Erdgas nach Deutschland
befördert das scheint jedenfalls schon
jetzt so gut wie ausgeschlossen
Lubmin im östlichen
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern hier enden die
rund
1.230 km langen Gaspipelines aus
Russland hier sollte nonstream 2 in
Betrieb gehen und auch das ist vorerst
vorbei wie geht es den 2000 Menschen die
hier leben viele hatten große Hoffnungen
in die gastrasse gesetzt auf jeden Fall
werden die
Gaspreise steigen
und ich denke vor allen Dingen an die
Leute dort es ist eine ganz schlimme
Sache
und die Region
ja es wird wahrscheinlich alles teurer
werden die ist gebaut das hatten auf dem
Geld gekostet das ist ein Gelder die wir
als Steuerzahler zahlen und die die das
beschließen dass das gestoppt wird die
haben wir fest ist ja halt die Branche
nicht viel kümmern aber wir wir müssen
sehen wie wir vorangekommen
Bürgermeister Axel Vogt ist besorgt
stolz war auf das Pipeline-Projekt Nord
Stream 1 spürt seit elf Jahren bis zu
zwei Millionen jährlich an Gewerbesteuer
Einnahmen in die Kassen ein Glücksfall
für die Kommune das Aus für die zweite
gasröhre Schütt Ängste um die
wirtschaftliche Existenz für den Fall
einer weiteren Eskalation des Russland
ukraine-konfliktes durchaus auch
Gaslieferung nach Deutschland teil
europäischer Sanktionen gegen Russland
sein können und damit steht dann
natürlich ein Teil der Finanzierung
unseres gemeindehaushaltes 22 auch in
Frage
ein kleiner Ort mittendrin im
geopolitischen Machtkampf die Kritik
wird lauter deutschland habe sich zu
abhängig gemacht von Russland die
Gasversorgung hierzulande basiert zu
über 80% auf Importen mehr als die
Hälfte des importierten Erdgases kommt
aus Russland
gerade für die deutsche Politik steht
jetzt die große Aufgabe an auch neue
import-routen für Gas nach Deutschland
zu schaffen wir hören die Diskussion
über lng-terminals in Deutschland wir
sehen allerdings dass hier bislang noch
nichts passiert hier muss die Politik
unbedingt auch durch Taten den Worten
entsprechend etwas folgen lassen
LNG Flüssiggas noch ist Deutschland
nicht so weit dass das Gas per Schiff
aus den USA oder Asien ankommen kann für
die Anlieferung von Flüssiggas muss
Deutschland ein Terminal bauen Stade ist
dafür vorgesehen doch dort kann es
frühestens 2024 beginnen was passiert
wenn Russland den Gashahn jetzt zudreht
noch ist Gas in den speichern wie hier
im niedersächsischen reden aber der
Füllstand ist niedrig
wir haben Gasspeicher in Deutschland die
sind jetzt Ende Februar zu etwa 30
Prozent gefüllt es finden ja auch die
Gespräche statt mit anderen möglichen
Lieferländern und dann wird Energie auch
teurer werden weil Energie dann knapper
ist aber trotzdem bleibt es dabei die
Kundinnen und Kunden brauchen sich nicht
Sorge zu machen dass jetzt der Wind im
Winter die Wohnung kalt werden würde
noch ist die Gasversorgung gesichert
aber Deutschland müsste seine
Gasförderung ausbauen unabhängiger
werden spätestens bis zum nächsten
Winter
ja die Gasförderung ausbauen
unabhängiger werden das ist gleich
gesagt aber möglicherweise schwer getan
fragen wir Janis kluge von der Stiftung
für Wissenschaft und Politik genannt der
kluge schönen guten Abend wäre denn
Flüssiggas tatsächlich auch eine
kurzfristige Alternative um Erdgas aus
Russland zu ersetzen
kurzfristig ist der Ausfall der
russischen Lieferungen wäre das kein
kritisches Problem es wäre kein
physisches Problem im Sinne das zu wenig
Gas zur Verfügung steht es würde zwar
die Preise massiv verändern und das
würden auch die Verbraucher merken aber
das große Problem ist eigentlich die
Frage was nächsten Winter passiert also
wie es gelingen kann jetzt im Laufe des
Sommers die deutschen Speicher wieder so
weit aufzufüllen dass man ja guten
Gewissens in den nächsten Winter gehen
kann und da spielt LNG eine große Rolle
woher nehmen wenn nicht stehlen woher
müsste man die deutschen Gasspeicher am
ehesten auffüllen
es gibt verschiedene Förderländer die in
Frage kommen es gibt klassische
Förderländer Vereinigten Staaten Katar
die sicherlich bereit werden nach auch
nach Deutschland nach Europa zu
verkaufen allerdings gibt es nur einen
begrenzten lng-markt insgesamt das heißt
die gesamten russischen Exporte nach
Europa zu ersetzen dafür ist der
weltweite lng-markt einfach nicht groß
genug und das ist das große Problem
deshalb wird es auch sehr stark darum
gehen den Verbrauch in Deutschland zu
verringern und noch alternative Quellen
zu finden und zu erschließen allerdings
muss man sagen noch ist es ein Worst
Case-Szenario das Präsident Putin
tatsächlich tut was zumindest doch
einige Regierungen in Europa nicht
ausschließen wollen nämlich den Gashahn
endgültig zudreht für wie wahrscheinlich
halten sie das
naja es ist von einem ja fast
ausgeschlossene Ereignis zu einem
geworden was was nicht unwahrscheinlich
ist es gibt eigentlich zwei zwei
Möglichkeiten wie das passieren kann
entweder ist es so dass Russland das als
gegen Sanktionen von sich aus tut also
den gashorn abdreht oder es kommt dazu
weil wir selbst nicht mehr zahlen können
beispielsweise weil durch eine Swift aus
Swift
Sanktionen eben die zahlungskanäle nach
Russland dann zu sind das zumindest ist
ein Szenario das im Moment noch nicht
Realität geworden ist aber offenbar auch
nicht mehr ganz so fern außerhalb
jeglicher Vorstellungskraft Herr kluge
danke für diese wenn auch kurzen
Auskünfte nach Berlin herzlichen Dank
Tag 3 der russischen Großoffensive eine
Invasion die man in Russland das haben
wir heute gelernt als solche nicht mehr
bezeichnen darf und auch das ist eine
Erkenntnis dieses Tages selbst
Kriegsherren wollen gegenüber den
eigenen Leuten lieber als Friedensengel
da stehen mit Gewissens Bissen hat das
aber eher nicht zu tun eher schon mit
reinem macht Kalkül das war unser
zdf-spezial das nächste folgt schon um
19 Uhr danke für Ihr Interesse auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
bleiben Sie immer aktuell informiert im
ZDF und der ZDF heute App
Berlin direkt mit Theo call
die russische Invasion in der Ukraine